Despite all the security measures,
today we managed to enter the European Commission.
We are going to show you around a little bit.
Because Europe is important for all of us.
And today we want to tell you why.
افتكر كده
as you can see they don't know what's coming what
these are the members of the European Commission
and if we are volunteering is also thanks to them so thank you
between the next 6th and 9th of June there will be the new European
elections to renovate the members of Parliament
and as a consequence also the members of the commission
because of this it's important to let our voice be heard
and how to do it vote
for ourselves and our communities vote
for our future
opportunities vote no no don't let others steal your voice
use it
vote the future is vote no Europe vote for Europe vote for Europe
vote vote
there vote